how did you get your first screenplay
option
there
was
a
screenplay that i wrote uh with a
writing partner of mine actually um it
was actually about a story about vince
mcmahon and the world wrestling
federation in case you know wrestling
but i happened to be really into that
world growing up watching it as a kid
and there was a particular event that
occurred within um
the the history of wrestling that that
is known as the montreal screw job and i
really really loved this idea and i kind
of thought hey this would make a really
great screenplay so
uh i sat down with my writing partner
and i did what i don't recommend anybody
do which is uh we just decided we were
going to write this thing that we you
know had no rights to we had no
connection to to
wwe in any kind of way it was just a
story that we were really passionate
about um
so we wrote this screenplay and my agent
at the time i told him i was like hey
i'm working on this thing i think it's a
really great idea and he was like okay
well you know you don't know any of
these people you don't have the rights
to that story the only way that this is
gonna go is you're gonna have to write
this thing
and you're going to have to send it to
you know wwe and then they're going to
have to miraculously want to read it and
then they're going to have to actually
want to like or they're going to have to
actually like it and then they're going
to have to actually want to option it
because you know it's you're dealing
with an ip that they own
um
and sure enough we got lucky and we
wrote the thing and we were just
confident with
what we thought we were writing and we
sent it over to my agent who got in
front of the people over there
and they read it and they they really
really loved it um and yeah and they
decided to option it from there
how long did it take you to write the
screenplay uh that one probably took
like i mean from the time when we
thought of the wanting to do the idea to
the time that we actually finished it
probably took a year
but not necessarily like a year of like
straight sitting at the computer writing
it was just
doing a lot of research thinking about
the idea thinking about if this is an
idea that we want to spend time writing
and then the actual writing process
probably took like
four five months or so
and so did you have a plan that if wwe
passed on it
the script was done like there was no
going further on it i think i think we
were just too naive at the time to like
to
think that this was probably
not worth writing or maybe you know
i i think from an outside go from an
outside perspective i was like oh like
well if it if it's good it's good you
know if someone wants to make this uh
who really knows maybe maybe someone
will
uh spearhead it so
we just we're passionate about it and we
just were like okay we'll write this and
hopefully
it gets in the right hands and and they
like it
and has it been made
it has not been made uh it's
it's i think it's gone around i mean
it's one of those things where
we were just writers on the script and
we kind of sent it off and they decided
to option it and um i actually don't
know like
how you know how much they've sent it
around i've had it come back to me where
you know i've been in general meetings
with other producers and i've made
mention like yeah i wrote the script and
blah blah blah and they'll say like oh
you know actually i read that and and i
think it's because maybe it did get sent
around a little bit
um but yeah i'm not i'm not currently in
control of it so it's just sort of out
in the filmmaking ether
is this something that you and your
writing partner
would duplicate again today like if if
you think just the naivete of
just being young and eager and wanting
to do this
was kind of like the the
forces were behind you and today knowing
more you wouldn't have the same luck
i guess i feel two ways about it one is
that um you know
when inspiration strikes and you're
passionate about something by all means
just write the thing that you're
passionate about so
on the one hand i don't want to like
discourage anyone from
writing the project that they or the
story that they want to tell but on the
other hand i do think that it's probably
a lot
a lot better use of your time to
work on a project or write something
that you're passionate about but is also
doable or doesn't require
a lot of
lawyers and ip
contracts getting involved because
even though that's a script that people
really love it's it's a complicated
thing to make happen because it's about
real people and
about a real life event so that's
definitely something that you know
i learned over the years and and
having written other scripts that have
gone on to be optioned
uh those ones i i realized okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna focus on things that you
know aren't contingent on a lot of other
factors
what is the real life event said the
montreal
yeah it's called the montreal screw job
uh there's plenty of you know
documentaries and youtube videos that
you can probably find out about it uh
but it's it is about vince mcmahon and
and
uh him dealing with his uh the the
off
the behind the scenes uh issues with
some of his uh roster talent
uh okay yeah i'm sure very interesting
colorful world full of glam as well
absolutely absolutely
um and so okay i'll
i'll google that and see
is this not safe for work conversation
or not
some of the stuff behind the scenes it
was just competitors trying to take
other people down yeah well i mean
without i guess without getting getting
too long-winded for it and this is me
not having my logline pitch ready for
you uh but the
about getting too long waiting for it it
was at a time when
um
uh
vince mcmahon and his company they were
starting to go out of business and ted
turner had gotten involved in wrestling
and became poaching a lot of talent to a
rival company called wcw
so uh
wwf had to kind of
revamp their product and they started to
get a little more edgy and and uh risky
with the products that they were doing
and one of their
superstars at the time was very
uncomfortable with the direction they
were going in and he was their highest
paid wrestler at the time and that
caused a lot of friction
in the backstage and vince mcmahon
wanted to oust him from the company and
get you know kind of a new generation of
wrestlers in there so
there was a lot of friction and then you
had drama backstage
leaking out into the on stage uh you
know performance of it all in life
imitating art and art imitating life
type type of situation which was really
interesting
so it'd be like if if film courage
wanted its screenwriters or filmmakers
to start throwing chairs and fighting
yeah something a little something like
that okay right i think we've seen that
not too far the talk shows yeah
right so so really up the the
controversy factor and yeah interesting
wow
you know i didn't know i don't know much
about the world of wrestling but i know
i find it fascinating and
um just all the show that's behind it
yeah yeah it is a very interesting world
i feel like there's nothing quite like
it as as far as like an entertainment
art form where it's this
never-ending
uh uh live performance soap opera that
has no off-season
sure and it seems like a lot of these
wrestlers have
turbulent lives off-screen yeah as well
yeah a little bit a little bit uh
celebrity actor meets you know rockstar
meets athlete all-in-one
right right yeah
fascinating
and so when you would watch
wwe growing up this was in the bay area
i guess sure what was your favorite was
it like rowdy roddy piper or forgive me
oh yeah some of these like oh all the
all the classics you know hulk hogan
growing up on that macho man and
ultimate warrior and then later on you
know you have brett hart and shawn
michaels and then you have stone cold
steve austin and the rock and people
like that so you know all the
generations
did you see fighting with my family
about paige i you know i actually didn't
see that one it's a great film oh yeah
okay i should check it out so it's
really well done and i watched part of
the documentary that was based on two of
how
she would go to these matches and yeah
um
sort of you know i think just in england
somewhere yeah yeah she she was very
passionate about it and yeah it's kind
of an interesting like based on a true i
mean she's a real actual wrestler and
they kind of made her her life story
into into the film yeah yeah and in the
law the glam that's behind it and yeah
and tragedy too so it's um
interesting did anyone try to talk you
out of it and say you know there's not i
mean you know the wrestlers fantastic
film that one wasn't over the top glam
but did anybody try to talk you out of
it and say don't no one cares about
wrestlers uh yeah i think i think that
there are
i mean there's no one that's like saying
like you know specifically don't do it
but there's definitely you know when you
when you talk about the idea there
people are like oh that sounds like a
tough one that's gonna be made and i
guess they're not there i mean they're
not wrong they're not wrong but there
was interest and you had an option i
mean that's yeah yeah there's something
to be said for them yeah they definitely
they definitely liked it and and yeah
it's they you know continue to re-up it
right because i might not be the right
demographic for that movie but i if i
saw that
advertised on the marquee if theaters
remain open whatever i would probably
want to go see it so yeah yeah it's
definitely definitely an interesting
very you know uh complicated human story
about you know
jealousy and betrayal and deceit and
things like that so you know even
outside of wrestling it's it's it's very
much
almost like a shakespearean kind of
drama
right i hope it gets made i'd like to
see it so yeah
you